be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is begin
getting into what I consider to be one
of the best stories ever written in
Marvel Comics Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four but because this story is
so expansive and there's other things
that I want to cover this series will
actually serve as a backdrop and that in
addition to my other videos this series
will be uploaded as well allowing for
two a days until we finish so instead of
going through and providing a large
narrative on why the story was written
instead what I want to do here is
provide this information as we progress
through the series itself and the reason
why is that for Hickman's Fantastic Four
the series actually draws this emphasis
from the entire history of the team with
special emphasis placed on Civil War
what I mean here is that with this story
having started in 2009 and civil war
having been written in 2006 prior to
Civil War reads role within the mobile
universe was largely that of an explorer
and chronicler of science and technology
however during the events of Civil War
and because the conflict was a symptom
of a larger problem involving the
warring nature of humanity Reed Richards
set about to quite literally solve the
problem of everything opening up with
Reed Richards and his father Nathanael
this particular bit of the story is
something I'd like you to keep in the
back of your head since the concept of
father and son will be a recurring theme
throughout this series especially
because a story itself largely
emphasizes Franklin Richards but this
moment comes to us as a flashback to
Reed's childhood but we will learn more
about the relationship between the two
within the well of Marvel Comics
Nathaniel Richards first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 272 as the father
of Reed albeit in an absentee form
however with these original appearances
from John Byrne almost no information
was offered about Nathaniel saved the
fact that he abandoned Reed Richards and
his mother three years before the
Fantastic Four gained their powers what
this expansion of Hickman does is
established that the moral compass of
Reed in terms of his willingness to fail
for the sake of discovering hails from
the lessons handed down to him by his
father who plays a significant part in
his life despite having been gone for so
long but following this flashback we
jumped to the present day with the
Fantastic Four facing off against a
villain
the wizard now in truth this battle is
not really designed to play any major or
significant part instead this is simply
designed to show us what the Fantastic
Four are doing in the current day and
that this era of their lives has them
fighting as superheroes and so with the
wizard defeated almost immediately after
sifting through the robots of the wizard
the Fantastic Four come to the
realization that the wizard himself has
been building robots designed to work as
proxies carrying out his will through
destruction now while this seems like
the normal actions of a villain after
accessing one of the robots
self-destruct mechanisms and tracing the
signal back to its source Reed arrives
at the Wizards lair only to discover
that he's been systematically developing
a race of robotic humans and children
while we don't know exactly what the
purpose behind this is Pikmin provides
us with an explanation when the story
shifts its focus to the aftermath and
the Baxter building where Johnny Storm
and Ben Grimm go about their normal
actions of jiving one another during a
conversation with Sue Reed's mind jumps
back to the wizard who argued off panel
that humanity would inevitably destroy
itself now again this ties directly into
civil war and now with Tony Stark
operating as a director of shield and
the fifty state initiative in place
which is to say a government-sanctioned
superhero team in all 50 states because
civil wars put the superhero community
down the middle with the remainder of
Steve Rogers Avengers operating
underground the Wizards claim of
society's imminent destruction rings in
the mind of Reed who's put his brain to
task and appears to have come to the
same conclusion and so taking to a room
within the Baxter building which is
off-limits to everyone else we
discovered that in addition to the
litany of ideas in the mind of Reed his
top goal at the moment appears to be his
desire to solve the problem of
everything now this bit is extremely
important because what Hickman is going
to do is effectively turn the entirety
of the Fantastic Four concept on its
head stepping into a multi-dimensional
bridge something that I hope you notice
is that if you see my videos on time
runs out this looks almost identical to
the device used by Reed to view the
multiverse in an attempt to decipher why
the multiverse was collapsing prior to
Secret Wars it's for this reason that if
you choose to the writings of Jonathan
Hickman within Marvel comics can
actually be read in isolation and in
chronological order revealing a complete
story unto itself dealing with multiple
facets of a superhuman commune
that said after initially speaking to a
disembodied voice we learned that these
men are actually different versions of
read from different realities what we're
told is that Reed Richards of r65 9 0
and Reed Richards of earth 12 hailed
from realities where the Fantastic Four
were exposed to the cosmic radiation
they granted their powers but instead of
developing the power to stretch their
bodies one gained the abilities of
Johnny Storm and the other gained the
abilities of Susan storm
now while Hickman will touch lightly on
the face of the other Fantastic Four
members from each of these continuities
for the moment Reed's taken before the
Council of Reed's within a hall that
exists outside of all space and time as
a result the council is able to perform
their work within the hall without
having to worry about negatively
impacting the multiverse around them in
addition to this after entering the hall
proper we learned that the council
consists of a litany of reads from
different realities and with different
powers as an example and one reality
Reed Richards is a mutant that leaves
the x-men but in another reality he
became a Silver Surfer or dr. strange
however before being able to receive a
proper tour and after the council is
alerted to an invasion of Earth by
Galactus in the 2:01 to reality Reed is
greeted by three versions of himself
with each one wielding an Infinity
Gauntlet
so with Fantastic Four number 571 the
comic picks up were 570 left off with
the castle preparing to do battle
against Galactus of Earth 2 0 1 2 now on
its face where this seems to be a
massive conflict that seven of the reads
have assembled to face off against
Galactus and three silver surfers we
actually learn that each of these reads
is wielding an ultimate nullifier that a
sidetrack for a second if you recall my
comic concepts video on the ultimate
nullifier itself we talked about how the
device serves to completely extinguish
and eliminate anything in existence up
to and including the universe while I
wouldn't say that this is a Glary plot
hole Marvel had previously established
that there was no limit to what the
ultimate nullifier could destroy within
any given universe meaning that a person
with the intelligence and willpower of
Reed Richards only really needs one
however with there being seven
nullifiers here the indication is that
perhaps this version of Galactus is too
powerful to be destroyed by a single
normal fire but it's entirely possible
that Hickman missed this piece of
information but regardless of the reason
for this following the off panel
destruction of Galactus we switch to
earth eight nine zero one as Reed is
being educated about the council's
purpose what we're told is that the Reed
from earth eight nine zero one initially
put his mind to task of solving the
universes issue of hunger by
terraforming a section of a barren and
uninhabitable planet while we're not
told how this was initially done what we
are told is that over time this 25
square mile hatch agree to cover the
entire planet and extend it to other
worlds within this universe as a result
the read of earth 8901
turned his sights to feeding the hungry
throughout the multiverse by using the
food from these planets to send supplies
through an interdimensional portal to
other realities in addition to this
while Reed Richards from the earth eight
nine zero one reality does possess an
Infinity Gauntlet the gullet only works
in the reality that it heals from now
this bit of information is extremely
important and the reason why is it prior
to this revelation the only information
on the limits of the gauntlet came
during the 2003 crossover JLA and
Avengers when Darkseid picked up the
gauntlet but couldn't use it however
with this statement hid been effectively
wrote the limit of the gauntlet in stone
making it in continuity which has
remained an aspect of his existence
ever since now from here we jump to the
earth 45 rial
on day three of Reid's education and
pickup with the darker side of the
council what we learn here is that
because the council exists to solve the
problem of everything not every solution
is peaceful or honorable instead the
council must occasionally delve into the
realm of the unthinkable in order to
keep the multiverse safe in this
instance because every story that
involves Doctor Doom sees him attempting
to gain absolute power for the goal of
ruling that reality the council had
taken it upon themselves to capture each
iteration of dr. doom which it aspired
to evil as a result and within the tomb
below the main council chamber are
countless versions of doom who have had
inhibitor collars placed around their
necks which destroys higher brain
functions and turns each version of doom
into a vegetable now on its face this
seems like an outrageous situation and a
complete paradox to the role of the
council in serving as a guiding force
for the universe but in truth I actually
agree with it decide check for a second
when I was younger I read a book called
injustice what's the right thing to do
by Michael Sandel and in it he provided
a scenario of a trolley train in this
situation you're the conductor of a
trolley when the brakes go out and the
only recourse you have is to adjust the
tracks if you stay on course you'll kill
five construction workers but if you
adjust course you'll kill only one this
situation falls directly in line with
the utilitarian philosophy of doing the
greatest good for the greatest number of
people however the other side of this
equation is the line-drawing if everyone
who demonstrates incorrigible evil is
stripped of their freedom and the goal
of the council is to solve the problem
of everything then stripping everyone of
their freedom is the only logical
conclusion to eliminating war and
conflict
now while this does fire allowed into a
ton of new arguments I'm actually
curious as to whether or not you all
agree with the idea of the council
stripping doom of his freedom and his
mind but following this situation we
transition to another flashback of reid
having a conversation with his father
discussing his troubles at school
instead of the issue being that reid is
constantly picked on the problem that he
faces is that no one in school is able
to keep up with them on an intellectual
level and that because of his
intelligence reid feels like an outcast
offering words of comfort nathaniel
states that the intelligence reid
possesses is a struggle at his young age
because he's not in position to use it
properly but when the time comes to
truly help the world reid will be able
to expand beyond his own sphere of
influence
and help more people that he can imagine
and so using this as a basis on the
sixth day we just welcome before the
council and asked to make a choice to
whether or not he's going to join the
council and solve the problem of
everything however before the council is
able to successfully induct Reid into
their ranks the Hall is besieged by
unseen forces switching to one of the
Reid's who makes mention that the bridge
of the multiverse has been compromised
what we're told is that a member of the
council had stumbled into the earth for
to 8/0 reality and discovered that the
Celestials of that universe had become
mad with power instead of serving to
explore an experiment the Celestials
instead use their combined abilities to
destroy the realities versions of
Galactus eternity and the other cosmic
entities after which they force the
inhabitants of the universe to worship
them and so as this video winds down
taking the council member and accessing
his mind through telepathy the
Celestials learned of the council's
existence and launched an attack with
the intention of expanding their sphere
of influence to all realities with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an and I hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will catch you guys later peace